since you've been gone is on that second
record yes i wish i wish to god i still
had the demo why because it sounds very
different howard
people don't understand why i fought it
at first and i'm like that's because you
didn't hear it so you hear it yeah and
really your thing with this song was hey
this demo just doesn't sound like me
it's not so you have to go back and and
change the arrangement and change the
vocals and and uh and kind of put your
own spin on the thing well and i think
honestly like in defensive max martin
like he wanted to make it like what it
ended up sounding like that's i think
because like i was like man i you know
they once i went to sweden and we
started talking about music like i was
like
i really think if we're gonna go this
route you gotta go for it like you gotta
put guitar we gotta have guitars y'all
like it was very it was very poppy like
puppy not like not pop rock at all all
right here we go we're gonna go back in
time all right here we go i'll quiet
them
[Music]
it was cool
[Music]
[Music]
since
[Music]
[Music]
but i can't breathe
[Music]
that song always gets me yeah i know
it's a great song now i love how you do
that